about the
cameras and stuff are they going
okay all right
okay well this is the work session on
hb 1258 which is the relative to the
implementation of the department of
energy uh we have a new amendment which
everybody should have a copy of now
and we know there's one thing that we
were going to put into this uh michael
maybe you can help with this and that's
uh cats uh
that other bill to combine it in here so
we'll have to work that in that's simply
just to take something that was in a
separate piece of legislation and
eliminate that and put it in here
because it has to do with the department
of energy anyways and we'll discuss that
interestingly enough it's it's 1285
going into 1258 okay
so we'll discuss that one afterwards
what i'd like to do now is this will be
a somewhat informal process i'd like to
ask the people from the department of
energy because they're the ones who
wrote up the amendment basically to just
start from the beginning and go over
what changes they made so if you want to
come up to the table here and we'll take
it from there
good morning just excuse me a question
from chairman votes
so my question is
does this amendment reflect
the document
that we shared with ols
as far as you're concerned
yes sir it does
um but there is
one mistake in what i sent over to ols
which we'll talk about as we go through
okay well gentlemen you have the floor
so how would you like to proceed would
you like to just go through the
the amendment itself yeah i think we
just start on the beginning of the
minute and go through and just some of
these are going to be fairly simple just
you know replaced uh
puc with uh doe but others may have a
little bit more background that we want
to talk about
um
so
section one of the bill
or of the amendment
is identical to
what was in the bill as introduced there
were no changes made in that section
in section two
this is
part of the change
that
modified
the bright red line
and which
made the department and automatic party
to proceedings before the public
utilities commission
okay to the on section two of of this i
have a note here from
this is having to do with i'm not sure
if this is the right place but it looks
like we're talking about the
rules here i guess it would be section
three
and
there was talk of a five-year rule
review
uh that we discussed
in the last meeting but i don't see that
in the bill anywhere and that was to try
to clean up some of the stuff problems
we had identified from the past
and
my apologies i did not include that uh
in what i provided to you for ols but
there's no objection to putting okay new
period in there come up with the best
place to put that in then yes okay
because we want to make sure i think
that's that that clears up another
problem that we so we don't have to pass
any additional legislation who's got the
question jackie go ahead
i quit section two on page
four we're not there yet right
that one
just go through
go through them when we get to that i
have a real problem with that okay
so anything else on page one
uh i just have a question
um on section two i was just reading
through it as you were referring to it
um attorney and it says that any
confidential information in discovery or
otherwise should be provided to the
department
um
so
if the department is already
a party
to
an adjudicative proceeding then wouldn't
then would they normally
receive confidential information
sent to the puc
so what
when the current department staff which
appears now as a party before the puc
was at the commission they automatically
received confidential information
pursuant to puc rule
but
there there is no such rule and there is
no
statute requiring the department
employees to get that confidential
information so we've requested it in
statute okay then so
and it is by statute that the
office of consumer advocate for instance
gets confidential information and
so the department is simply asking for
that same type of provision in the
statute so that there's no question
that they they're privy to any of
utilities confidential information so
that they can perform the functions of
their job so follow up i think that's i
tried to get at this question in the
last hearing and i believe
chairman bose had something to say and
you didn't answer me
does this then present a problem in
taking those resources out of the public
utilities commission and putting them in
an agency
where
they now have the same responsibility
but they're under different jurisdiction
in other words that that that's where
the
inconsistency in the statutes is coming
from is that those resources
who who handle those things or had
handled those things
are being asked to continue to handle
those things but in a different role
or you know in a different agency under
a different heading in terms of
organizational yeah i don't i don't
think that there's any problems so long
as the rules are spelled out in the
statute which they are
okay and so that means that those folks
will not be discussing the confidential
information that they receive with other
people in doe that are not related to
their jobs or
does that
that is correct
okay yeah thank you is it safe to say
then what we're doing here is that the
we've transferred the
work function and the people to the
department of energy and so now we're
transferring the authority to see
confidential information to that same
group in a different department exactly
so they can perform their job like they
did before yes okay
on to page two
okay so
uh
section section three on page two i
we discussed that in the context of
placing a five-year period uh in that
is it in there
anywhere the five years because i didn't
see it he has to add it he said i'll
now we can move on to page two i guess
so no go ahead jackie i want to go back
to what you just said
about confidential information that
puc has i just want to clarify puc has
the ability and the right to get
confidential information when it's
discussing a case department of energy
has the right to get that information
if if i'm interpreting what you said
correctly
and
the consumer advocate has that right
that's correct
that's one heck of a chain of custody
with the way it was presently set up the
puc and the consumer advocate had it but
now that we've got the department of
energy we have to address that and what
this does is addresses that and allows
the department of energy to get that
confidential information and
and does that assume that the department
of energy is a party to any of those
adjudicative processes
yes so under the current statute the
department is a party to any
adjudication before the commission
under the current statute
yes and and you did that without any
information
parties provided us with the
confidential information so that we
could do our job it just wasn't
specified in statute
but the utilities have been cooperative
in that regard
uh so at the top of uh page four
um the three lines that are crossed out
are the pre or the fuzzy red line that
we'd like to make the bright red line on
the previous page
lines four five and six you'll see here
deleted
top of page two i'm sorry
line four line four page two yeah
yeah
it was a long weekend
so no questions on that
okay
this is this isn't new this was
something we had had in here before yeah
right
so
mr chairman
i i actually think this is the language
that sort of relates to what i was
getting at which says the stuff that's
crossed out starting at line three
provided that other than the
administrative functions department
employees shall not communicate with the
public utilities commission and its
staff in connection with any issue
in a matter pending before the
commission i mean why is that language
stricken because that's exactly what i
was asking um that language is actually
replaced with other language which is on
page one
and you'll find it on lines 19 and 20.
so that in adjudicative proceedings the
public utilities commission and the
department are subject to a provision of
541a
and that is a provision that prohibits
ex-parte contacts
with someone who's in a sort of a
judicial
or advisory capacity
so
the language that you see on page two
um
is is broader than the language in the
administrative procedures act it is and
has proven to be somewhat problematic
because matters aren't defined it's not
limited to adjudicative proceedings
um it would include probably rule
makings you know if push came to shove
and there's there's really no reason for
that we ought to be able to coordinate
our rule makings to make sure that we're
doing them correctly and
uh dividing our responsibilities
appropriately
um
and
there was
confusion
within
the commission and the department and
among the relevant parties as to what
was administrative and what was not
so
people were having difficult
difficulty communicating
with the clerk
at the puc and getting information out
it made participating in a docket quite
problematic
but the language in
541a
is relatively well understood it's the
same language that any other
uh
agency is is subjected to when they're
acting in a quasi-judicial capacity
so that would eliminate the confusion
and allow the cooperation where it's
helpful
but it also kind of addresses the issue
that's been a concern over the years and
that's that when when the puc as it used
to be
they had the staff and that was sort of
like
sorry
i feel like i'm leaning over the table
bro there we go
so but the the staff had direct access
to the commission where the utilities
didn't that was considered ex-part-time
so this sort of addresses that issue to
clarify
when and where the uh
the staff whatever staff in this case
department of energy can have direct
access to the commissioners right and
and
so
actually what when staff was at the
commission
those
and and commission staff was speaking
with the commissioners that was not
considered
ex parte under 541a right there was a
different provision that applied
to
uh
puc staff in an adjudication
um
that was eliminated in house bill 2.
but there was a special provision that
governed
the conversations between staff members
and and commissioners it's different
from the one cited here but the but the
con i'm sorry go ahead jackie you've had
your hand up a while i was just going to
say but the confusion is because we've
reorganized them so that their staff no
longer belongs to them
that's why this confusion right because
regulatory and executive branch are not
the same yeah i think the confusion was
the language that was chosen on page two
the appropriate language in that
circumstance is the language in rsa541a
which was what we're asking you to
substitute
okay yeah thanks go ahead jackie
541a as as i thought i heard you say it
was that
it
did not allow ex part day communication
is that correct
that's correct that's correct so now as
i am
listening to this
with my
very normal brain
does this forbid
the puc
and
the department of energy from talking to
each other about confidential
information
and if it does why do they each need it
right that's just
is does that do that
okay so
utility
some of the information that's provided
by utilities is
confidential by statute some of it is
confidential
because it's really nobody's business
who their customers are by name or
sometimes by address right
and some of their internal financials
are confidential
when you do after you do the
the balancing that's required under 91a
right
but in order for everyone to perform
their job and regulate the utilities we
have to review that language or you know
that that information right
um
and and so everybody has to have access
to it that doesn't mean
that
we're
talking to each other about it behind
the other party's backs that's what ex
parte means it means if you're going to
have a conversation about it about that
information then that conversation has
to
occur in front of all of the parties to
the docket but that's different from who
has access to the information
that you would have the conversation
about
if that makes any sense yeah jackie
would be like for example let's just say
there was a rate case and so the
department would be looking at that for
their what they think the appropriate
rate increase like should say should be
for a utility well in order to make that
decision in order to
build develop what their position is
they're going to need access to that
confidential information and obviously
so is the commissioners are going to
need it as well because they'll make the
final call on it but it doesn't mean
that the commissioners and the
department are going to be discussing
that information back and forth they're
just both going to have it so they can
both do their jobs so can i follow up
sure sure the follow-up would be then
it would be possible and i
again in my normal mind that the
department of energy and the public
utilities commission
could not come up with the same
conclusion
and then what happens there well
who then decides
quote unquote whose conclusion is
more in the public interest or more
correct and i'm not sure when you say
conclusion you mean conclusion of what's
confidential a conclusion of the
disposition of a rape case the
disposition of the red case that'll be
the puc they have the adjudicative
authority to do that and they'll put out
the decision the department of energy
would be you might be able to look at
him as if you know had a plain event or
defended i don't like to use those terms
but people can understand what i'm
talking about
they both make recommendations let's
just say utility x comes in and says
based on all of our experts in 10 days
of testimony and 55 500 pages or
whatever we think we should get a 3.8
rate increase the department of energy
looks at all the same thing and says no
we think it should only be a 3.3 percent
increase that's going to go to the
commission and the commission will rule
they might rule one way or the other or
they may rule something different but
they have the final saying they have the
final say
but
and again in my mind the way it's
working the department of energy has the
purse strings over the public utilities
commission
well not really i i think their funding
is independent like from that they get a
the money comes in by formula you can
help me out here david but i'm pretty
sure it just goes all into a bucket at
the department of energy and then by
fixed formula so much of that is given
to the puc so it's not a determination
of the department of energy correct the
budgets of the public utilities
commission the office of consumer
advocate and the department are
determined
by the governor and the legislature
you decide
who gets how much money
right
all the department does is collect it
and put it into the kitty to be
distributed
right but it is the legislature and the
governor who decide the actual budgets
and you know each agency is responsible
for developing its own budget the
department
you know provide some back office help
you know to those agencies to help them
put that stuff together but it's really
their budget they take it to the
legislature and and you folks decide
move down the page then
please
okay uh section five
um
the deletion that you see that says the
division shall be an automatic party is
replaced by a sentence on page one that
says the department shall automatically
be a party right
no reason to make just one division
a party
because many of our divisions
participate
uh section six
um is the
um
provision that we requested to extend
the life of the
um
uh the pucs procedural rules
until we can get procedural rules in
place which should occur
sometime this year
section 7
this is identical to what was in the
bill is introduced and it essentially
places replaces the commissioner of the
public utilities commission with the
commissioner of the department of energy
on the sustainable energy board
uh on page three
section eight
this changes some references in
the regi statute from the commission to
the department of energy that have to do
with developing a report to the
legislature
it's the department that really develops
that report and this language just
reflects that
and just so we're clear here in this
section since we're dealing with i
assume it's 125.
when you say department you mean des
and then department of energy is
department of energy correct that's
correct okay so um
this assumes that the legislative
oversight committee is not going to be
repealed as we have another bill pending
on that
that's correct
um
so
at the end of last week as we were going
through 125.0 and doing this work we
found a few more
references that probably should be
changed which i will be floating to you
in an email
probably tomorrow i just need to make
sure i i need to discuss it with the
public utilities commission to make sure
they're on board with the changes that
we would
suggest making
um
uh
before we leave this page i had a
question on
uh section 10 we talked about for good
cause and after notice and hearing the
department of energy may accelerate a
delay up to one year okay this has taken
effect a couple of times now it's been
in effect for some of the wood plants or
whatever because they um
first of all it's only class one and
class two is that the way it is now
because i thought they did it for the
for the uh old wood burning plants
because we just don't have enough of
them running anymore i think um for the
class three plants it's a complete
change in the in the requirement it can
right it can um
that's covered someplace else which is
it is okay but on this one
making that go to the department of
energy the reason i just want to bring
this up and this is for everybody in the
commission the committee's input as well
is this could actually affect rates
because if you go out and you say
you have to have i'm just making up
members it has to be 10 of your energy
has to be from solar and you change that
to 5
or you change that to 15
um
that means the utility has to go up and
buy more or less wrecks which is going
to change rates
so should that be done by the department
of energy or should the
and i put this as a question or the puc
should just take that as an input and
say because this has changed it's gone
down now the rate should go down
accordingly or because it's gone up the
rate should go up accordingly well i
i think this
is appropriately at the department
right
the
public utilities commission
might decide what the rate change
actually is
what the department would be deciding is
whether there's good cause
to change a programmatic feature okay so
move the percentages one way or the
other okay i just wanted to make sure
people understood that that's a that's
sort of a change because it's
reggie is sort of with the department of
energy but in this case it'll directly
affect i mean the rps but it'll directly
it could directly affect rights if that
was changed right
peter go ahead
um
mr shillock can you just give me an idea
what what the interpretation of a good
cause is
i understand that it says for a good
cause and after hearings and so forth
but
what are typical good causes where you
want to do that
can you just make up any cause you want
well i would suspect that the types of
causes that
people would
propose would would be
say for some reason there there were
numerous retirements
uh
that that would affect the supply of
wrecks
right
and
trying to think i think
we had a situation something like that
when
um the
steam plants here in town
stopped burning
right
stopped burning wood
um and so there was going to be a
shortage in one of the areas and that
that was good cause i believe at the
time to to delay and increase
i mean not only was there a shortage it
was a permanent one right and there's
nothing we could really do about it in
the short term but to be quite honest
with you peter that's a great question
but i can remember when this was being
debated i think i was at the commission
at the time
and
that was the best words we could come up
with that was so it's it's they're not
perfect but if you can kept up with
better ones let me know
okay thank you
so uh section 11 was a request of the
public utilities commission to change
the requirements of what needed to be
described in their final orders
and it removes the requirement that um
the commission
state the position of each party on each
issue
it doesn't prohibit them from doing that
it just doesn't require it in every
order and just so people are clear the
the the entire history of those
positions is there in it you can look up
a docket and you'll find the filing of
eversource the filing of unitil or
whatever and it'll give their complete
position what's been done in the past is
then in the order that the puc puts out
they will summarize that position of the
various parties and put it in their
order it really has no legal bearing
because it's just saying this is this is
our interpretation of their opinion of
what these what they submitted so what
they actually submitted is still there
open to the public and everybody can
read it so um can i ask what the
exemption in rsa 541 a29 and rsa 541
a29a are
because it's saying except for those
and i don't think we unders you know we
probably don't know what those are that
are being exempted
so um
page three yes i'm sorry yeah page yep
so we're on page two again bottom of
page three very
final orders is what i'm referring to
okay so um rsa
541a29 has been around for a while and
that is a provision that requires an
agency when it receives an application
or a request
it requires within a certain amount of
time that the agency identify the person
who's handling that request
and that the
agency state
you know what is missing you know in
terms of information from the request
what what is unclear
uh etc that timeline
uh used to be 60 days
and then it requires action
on
the application
it used to be 120 days
a few years ago that was changed
to 30 days
and 60 days
otherwise the agency had to open an
adjudicative proceeding
right
also just a few years ago rsa 29
the 29a section was added and that
section states that you know unless
there's some other
timeline specified to the contrary um if
the agency fails to meet the timelines
in
29 then the application or request is
automatically granted
as a matter of law
right
and
uh the pc that a means of enforcement
really
it's a means of it's trying trying to
get agencies to do things
to prevent long delays the problem with
the puc is there's been a number of
times when they actually get filings
from individuals or small groups of
people
and uh you know i'm sure david can
give you more about this
it's just totally incomplete it's you
have to you almost have to walk them
through the process and say you didn't
do this you didn't do that and then
they'll refile and go on some of these
things we had a case i'm always wearing
one in bedford for the individual
household who said we were selling them
bad they was getting sold bad
electricity whatever the hell that means
but uh and that went on for i don't know
two or three years i think before it was
finally settled so this just allows the
uh people to work with the um
especially private individuals where
with the utilities they have their own
lawyers and everything and it doesn't
i've never seen it as being an issue for
those well i i mean i think some of the
language before this addresses that
though it says you know that that um the
agency when they receive a request
they're required to assess define and
define what's missing within a certain
period of time right so if they've
defined that an application comes in
that's
problematic or you know even if they
can't secure the information right if
they've reached out to the parties that
are responsible for that incomplete
information
they would have met their requirement
they shouldn't be have it waived i mean
i just i'm just trying to figure out
whether this makes things better or
worse you're not waiving that
requirement but when you send it back
out to them then it could be a month or
two before they respond and then that
deadline for finally the final decision
would have passed and that's that's the
reason they allowed okay yeah i think
it's almost always people that are
filing is a you know they don't have the
legal skills because they're not a
utility with a staff a lawyer so yeah
okay
and
and the agencies were never staffed to
handle those types of timelines right it
was difficult even with the 120 days the
60 days it was nearly impossible
so for instance when the consumer
affairs division was at the puc they got
10 000 contacts a year yeah among five
people right right and so just
and you know the types of requests that
would come in
often required a lot of hand-holding
right yeah uh with with uh individual
rate payers and
a lot of escalating with the utilities
and
not really possible to do it within
those timelines and and most of the
requests weren't really
suitable for automatic grant
right they would be problematic if you
just automatically granted the request
that came in from the consumers
go ahead jackie
does any of this encompass the site
evaluation committee
no no
no
but the site
evaluation committee is kind of a
hanging out here by the department of
energy
so the the site evaluation committee is
an independent committee
right made up made up of representatives
from different
agencies at the state
it's only
administratively attached to the
department
the department doesn't even have a
member
on on the sec
right
and there is a major uh
amendment a change to that coming out
coming from the senate side
michael is that past the senate do you
know
okay but it's it's over there anyways
yeah at this point all we would do is
provide some back office support to the
uh committee
so the rest of these on page four unless
someone has another question looked like
just changing commission to department
of energy
to make two pages
is that correct
so
i don't see any policy changes other
than they just right place
commissioned with the department of
energy that's correct and that's just um
to make sure that the department is able
to collect the assessment and distribute
it to the other agencies
mr harrington sure go ahead
section
section two on page four
um
that concerned me because we had given
up
all
control
over communications and we're still
assessing
and we're still getting reports and
we're still
requiring things of them that we no
longer have any
jurisdiction over and i wonder why
that's still in there or
that happened years ago when
nato cain was the chair
and we wondered if that was a good idea
and then we heard that the assessment on
the communications
here
one of the testimonies was it had
doubled
and i wondered why when
we don't have any
so the assessment statute was revised
when the legislature reduced the
regulation of telephone companies right
um and they went from a full asses
100 uh
100 assessment on their revenues to a
third
right
so
their assessments were reduced
considerably at that point
um
and the changes that you see here which
just refer to the collection don't don't
affect the level or amount of their
assessment the the changes on page four
are really
just mechanical
that they don't go to the level
um of the assessment or how much a
telecommunications company might owe
this is just the mechanics of the
collection
and if you get down the road that may be
an issue worth pursuing because it was
kind of hanging from when the telephone
deregulation remember it wasn't
completely because basic service is
still covered but it's a separate issue
from this this is just as david said if
this is just saying commission goes to
department of energy and it's not making
an opinion on those assessments but it's
possibly something for future
legislation but they're still collecting
those revenues and and as we heard here
they're doubling and that just
my point is it's just it's not really
within the scope of what we're trying to
accomplish in this bill it's
i'm not saying something we shouldn't
look at but that would be something we
might want to look at in the future and
not try to get it in here because we
start getting to that level we'll still
be here three months from now working on
this bill so
thank you mr chairman um i actually have
a question at the top of page four
on the section on final order shall
include but not be limited to
and it looks like
two three and
uh or
they were items two three and four now
they're uh two three and three are
have been xed out one way or another and
so all the final order needs to include
is the identity of all the parties
and i'm i'm actually concerned with
eliminating the concurrence or dissent
of each of the commissioners
participating in the decision because
those haven't been eliminated i mean
maybe it's just the way that every
number yeah
okay so three is two and three is two
and four is three yeah there is no there
is no yeah so this should be
that the two should be pushed down if
you will next line i got you okay so you
left the two but switch okay the only
thing was taken out was the position of
each party makes sense great
sorry on to page five then right so um
section
15.
hold on a second
uh section 15 deals with rsa 363 b
and these changes are made to
clarify
that it is the department of energy that
would review terminations and uh
terminations of service and
disconnections of service
all the staff that that does that work
is now located at the department not at
the commission
well i just want your question if
they're part of an agency though
then are they still going to have the
same kind of independence to make those
decisions because it seems like
politics can infiltrate there in terms
of what those decisions are
are those people going to be
uninhibited
in a role within an agency uh no the the
disconnections and terminations are
governed by rule
right so they're they're highly
structured
and the um
all of the detail work is conducted by
those people in the consumer division
right
and you know there's a whole long
process for contacting and setting up
mediations with the company etc and then
when it comes to terminations of service
especially for medical disconnections
utilities have to
demonstrate that they've provided all
the proper notice and gone and knocked
on doors etc and all of that's
controlled by rule uh so very highly
structured yeah i do i do understand but
we just had an issue with energy
efficiency which was similarly well
defined in process
um in terms of how this it would be
approached and how it would be reviewed
and how it would be administered through
the puc and it
didn't didn't help right
the the rules on the disconnection are
pretty long and detailed uh some of
which go back to
and i'm not sure if you were here then
david's probably 10
15 years ago and i think it was
it was one of the utilities that's no
longer in the state but they had a
person die okay it was
enough and it was
june 21st 2010. okay
and that they died when they
disconnected and after that there was a
big redo of it and there's all sorts of
rules but you can't disconnect in the
wintertime and you have to go out like
in person i think it's in-person contact
with anybody that's on a medical device
that registers and now i you probably
noticed you started getting phone calls
from the utilities saying we could have
a power outage be aware if you're
someone on a medical device so forth and
so on so i think that's pretty well
structured uh structured yeah
that was a major waking up point when
that person died so
good memory david by the way well
some things are hard to forget
so
um
so section 16.
this differs from what was in
the bill is introduced the bill is
introduced would have limited
the
investigations that could be transferred
to the puc for adjudication to just
violations by utilities that limitation
has been taken out here
and then
new language
was inserted here
to clarify
what would happen to a complaint filed
at the department that the department
didn't think should be transferred to
the puc and it the new language allows
the party
uh itself to to take the complaint to
the puc to perhaps get a hearing
okay that resolved one of our major
issues that we were discussing i've had
a big note about that so that's a big
improvement i think it's it does give
that adjudicative process we had
discussed going to the supreme court was
the next movement we didn't want to do
it that way so this is this i think is
an improvement that everyone had agreed
to
so then page beginning on page six these
are changes to the
uh crossing statute
right
and pursuant to that statute
the state gives utilities and companies
that provide utility type services
licenses to cross state land and state
water with their equipment
that procedure was fully adjudicative
prior to the reorganization
and it was all adjudicated at the public
utilities commission
now in reality the
there were very very very very very few
hearings on on those licensings
the commission
would issue
what would would take the license
application review it
and
normally grant the license by an order
nice eye and give people the opportunity
to request a hearing if they wanted one
and
in
the vast majority of those cases nobody
ever requested a hearing
the commission would when a crossing
appeared to be
controversial
have the utility publish it in the
newspaper and on their website etc
to give the public notice that somebody
had even applied for the crossing and
even then very few people would come in
and
contest the license
house bill 2
divided
that process in two
and said that whenever all the parties
agreed
the department could issue the license
right and then allowed for a hearing
before the puc
um if
the
uh if the parties disagreed right the
the problem was there was no way to
determine who the parties were unless
you opened up an adjudication so we
ended up with two adjudications one on
the department side and one on the
commission side and that first
adjudication is really sort of
unnecessary right so what this statute
revision does is it asks
to to make
the
the proceedings before the department
um fully administrative
right so the the
application would come into the
department the department would review
it would grant or deny
the license
at that point
a publication would be made so that the
world would know that a license was
granted and people would be given an
opportunity to request a hearing if they
wanted one which sort of mimics what the
public utilities commission was doing
all along that first part was more or
less administrative they would publish
the order nice eye and give people the
opportunity to request to hearing this
this sort of
follows that model a little bit more
closely
um
yeah just david if i just interject with
what he's saying is 100 these things
used to show up these order nice size
you'd get them on friday morning you'd
pick them up they'd be like two or three
pages you'd spend 15 minutes reading
them and you'd sign the order in a way
it would go there was no hearings there
was no debate because they were all
totally routine so doing
administratively is should be no problem
especially if there is an option to
appeal to the puc so i think jackie had
her hand at first then
that's a quick question okay collect
questions take priority questions what's
nice i
uh without you
it's uh it's without a hearing and with
opportunity to request one essentially
please spell nice n-i-s-i
yeah
it's probably some latin words i'm
guessing
anyways go ahead jackie i was listening
or trying to listen carefully to what
you were saying mr shulock
and it sounded to me like first you
issue the license then you get the
hearing and so then if
if you haven't a problem
or if there's a major problem with that
license or
con contestation
then you would remove the license or
deny it it it just seemed like
right so under the order nice i process
yeah person had the opportunity to file
comments and an objection and request a
hearing and if after the hearing
the
commission believed that the license
shouldn't be granted the license would
never go into effect
right
they would pull back their order
he's actually under the new process how
would that work under the new process
the license would be granted publication
would be made
and at that point people could request a
hearing
when they request the hearing if the
puc disagrees and thinks that the
license should not have been issued
they can
order the the department to pull the
license
that's the way that this is set up
clunky yeah i have a question
uh thank you thank you for taking my
question
um
so
this is licenses for new polls and i'm
i'm curious how this would be affected
with the 5g
technology that's pending because we've
had you know numerous hearings on
the frequency
of
additional polls that will be needed to
support that new technology
so i'm just wondering is this is this
the kind of thing where a large-scale
project of that sort could be approved
by the department of energy
um second part of the question is and
how long do people have to file if they
would like to have it heard at the puc
is there a window there that because
oftentimes the public isn't aware that
something's been granted so okay so i
can help out here i think the key thing
is on this paragraph is that that any
public utility should construct pipeline
cable conduit a line of poles towers so
forth the cell companies aren't public
utilities
so i don't think this paragraph applies
to them one way or the other um
so
the 5g facilities
might be attached to a utility structure
so it might apply then and then the
statute also reply applies to
corporations
that want to cross and and they they
have to
do the same application and get the same
type of license that the utility would
so it's not just
not just utility public utilities
but you know this this
would only be for a small portion this
would be
you know if they needed to cross a state
park
right so it would only be for that
portion it wouldn't be for the entire
project
right okay so just this is just state
land state waters as it states okay
thank you
it's hard to
keep asking
one of the other big differences between
what's being proposed here and
the statute as it currently exists is
the current statute has a number of
exemptions
or
licenses by notification
the time period for some of those for
the licenses by notification has sort of
expired there was an original two-year
time period in the statute for that
um
so that that's been eliminated um there
was an exemption
from licensing for the crossing of state
lands for the purposes of serving the
state
right
um that this would do away with all the
exemptions and the notifications
and require everybody to obtain a
license and for every crossing to be
reviewed by the department for at least
safety
right
and the idea is that rather than having
exemptions or
such in the statute the department's
rules would
would apply the level of scrutiny
required for each type of crossing
right rather than just saying you're
exempt
right
yeah
age seven i see almost no change one it
says the commission down the bottom up
on line 33 right
so um
down to line 27 that's all part of the
crossing statute that we just discussed
right
then
uh
section 19 uh is as it appeared in the
bill is introduced there are no changes
there that you that we asked for
okay
so on to page 8. same for section 20 at
the top of page 8.
but when you get down to section 21
this has to do with the attachments
uh statute the poll attachment statute
and
there was some back and forth about
which
agency should retain its authority over
safety and vegetation management and
having discussed this with the public
utilities commission
we think it should be both agencies
retaining that authority because we each
have a little in different areas
this is section 21
section 21 starting on line eight page
eight yeah uh i actually don't
understand what happened up up above
that on line one
because the public good i thought was
part of the public utilities commission
charge
and all those factors that are being
considered there seem like they would be
with the utilities commission not with
the department of energy so i'm
questioning that yeah so the the public
good is just a standard
it says nothing about who would
apply it
right so
the
the bulk of this statute to which this
supplies is
um
within the department of energy's
jurisdiction and
i think you can look at
the change on page one is just an
oversight when when they were moving
things over in house bill 2.
question i automatically have when you
have two agents is in charge of the same
thing
how do you work it out when there's
maybe some differences of opinion right
um
i guess that remains to be seen
right
i didn't specifically ask this of the
utilities and the ones that were here
said that they could live with this
wording uh because i have the same note
down as fred is that you know when you
have two agencies what we don't want to
do is have uh
well you know the commission said i
should do this and i did it and then the
department says no no no you need to do
something else so all i can say is this
one uh we'll be watching close
and if this doesn't work we'll have to
make some adjustments in the future but
i don't know i'm willing to say give it
a shot because the utilities didn't
object how does the rest of the
committee feel
okay go ahead fred
i could see something like uh what
happened before that uh
the the
department of energy has the
responsibility but if somebody doesn't
agree they could go to the puc for
adjudication
so um
this provision uh on line eight
doesn't actually say
who has what authority
that's not the purpose of this paragraph
so this is in the poll attachment
paragraph
which allows utilities
to contract
with other companies about
what they will attach to their polls and
how
right
um and what they'll pay for that right
um all that this paragraph says is that
the utilities can't contract away the
state's ability to regulate
by contracting right that's the purpose
of this paragraph and so to the extent
that the puc or the department have any
authority over
vegetation management which they do or
safety which they do the utilities can't
bargain that away in a poll attachment
agreement
that's all that this is saying
thank you but that doesn't eliminate
potential for conflict
oh no i think you're absolutely right
about that right
uh one other question just on one
wording on line nine
where it talks about the department of
energy and the public utilities
commission shall retain their authority
well
the department of energy never had any
authority so they can't retain it so
wouldn't be a little bit more correct to
say the department of energy and the
public utilities shall have the
authority to regulate
because they're not the public
department energy is not retaining
anything because it didn't have anything
to retain well
it depends on if you're looking at this
at the time that this gets enacted
or if you're looking at it in the
context of
the utility just bargained for something
but
even when they bargain tomorrow
the department is going to retain
whatever authority it has
overseas it's not that big of a deal
right if you think it's okay the way it
is but i i will get back i don't think i
would change it to us
i don't think i would change it to a
statute that actually says that both
have authority over these two things
that's the problem that i think we're
trying to get away from i would just
like to ask the members of the
subcommittee though is i mean fred has a
a valid point we have two
you know possibly conflict conflicting
even though we know they're a big happy
family now um is that something we want
to go forward with and see how it works
or do we want to say like what fred
proposed having
one have initial authority and one have
appellate authority and i'm just because
i mean this is a question that's going
to have to come up so what do people
think because when we just go around the
room
hit your microphone please
i actually prefer it being left just the
way it is okay
i would prefer that the
public utilities retain the authority
when we say retain when they would have
the appellate authority and the
department of energy would have the
initial review no that that the
department of energy be left out of that
because there's a pending sale of polls
going on too so i think that public
utilities
is where this belongs okay
jackie
the kate i mean
pat
oh
yeah no i i actually agree that i still
think it's it's with the public
utilities and
i think that where the confusion comes
in is that many of the resources that
are making some of these determinations
and have the expertise are from the
public utilities staff who are now
residing in the department of energy and
so it's just made it more confusing
as to how these these things get
accomplished but i think
the public utilities commission has a
separate uh
mission and i i do think that these
pieces are regulatory in nature and
that's why i would agree with jackie
michael
you're here you may as well get your
opinion
page eight
yeah yes
turn on your microphone
yeah should it be sorry this this
basically way it's set up now is it the
department and the commission both have
equal authority
uh
fred had raised the question of
is that going to cause problems because
you have two departments and none of
them has the final say
so
what jackie had suggested is just get
the department of energy out of it but
as k cat is brought up the problem is a
lot of the people that have the
expertise are now with the department of
energy so i think eliminating them
completely would be difficult
fred suggests the possibility of the
initial approval going through the
department initial review going through
the department of energy and then if
there was an appeal to that it would go
to the public utilities commission for
final uh well my question would be why
did
why was it suggested by the department
of energy that the public utilities
commission shall be
added to the statute because apparently
it wasn't there before
so the current statute says that it's
the department that shall retain its
authority and the reason for that is
i mean it is the context of the statute
itself this statute only deals with
attachments to polls
right
and
in the context of that statute utilities
enter into agreements with people who
want to attach
and they can put all kinds of provisions
in those agreements that the state
doesn't regulate
all this says
is that the utilities can't bargain away
the state's regulatory authority
over things like safety and vegetation
management etc it doesn't say anything
about who actually has that authority so
for instance you know we have safety
rules right and we'll probably
uh adopt some additional safety rules
what you know as we get going right
vegetation management
that's all handled in dockets there is
no rule that governs vegetation
management
um that's that's really
um
done sort of in in the context of rate
making
believe it or not where um you know
you're deciding
what goes into which budget and how
readily accessible that money is to the
utility through their their rates right
uh when they get paid back for the work
that they're doing that sort of thing
right and so that's that's more
within the pucs can and the people at
the department are taking a position
under their regulatory authority which
is
basically to take a position and argue
right on that subject and then it gets
resolved by the puc so there is no
clean line that we can draw
in this area
at least not at this point i think
that's a project that's well beyond what
we can do here
um in in this session but on things like
safety for example the people that would
be
responsible for that would be are in the
department of energy and not in the puc
those those people have been moved over
correct
um
yes those people have been moved over
but that doesn't mean that they wouldn't
appear before the puc to make arguments
on an issue that the puc would have the
decisional authority for
right so was this original change to
statute made by hb2
right so the original statute said the
public utilities commission shall retain
its authority right
house bill 2 changed that to the
department
shall
retain its authority and what the puc
and the department are suggesting to you
is that it should be both
right so whatever
authority
the each one has they retain it in that
that process the utility
cannot be permitted to bargain that away
in its attachment agreements
i'm satisfied with this language as
written fred
listening which i sometimes do
uh
i think that uh
leave it alone let's see if the plate
let it play out and see if there's a
problem in the future
because i heard about the
the the it's too difficult to unwind the
department has this and puc has that
some of it's in a rate case some of it's
some of it's administrative so let's
leave it alone and see what the problem
wraps up in the future i may have been
thinking of a problem that won't exist
well you know i i think these are things
that you do need to think about right as
as do we and we're going to be thinking
about this as we go through our
rule-making project this year right
we'll be working with the department of
justice on that to make sure that we're
appropriately assuming the authority
that we should assume and not assuming
authority we shouldn't each agency
right and
i think after that if there are problems
they'll be they'll become more clear
right such as well
if if the department sets a rule can the
commission require something some
some type of behavior that's
above and beyond
the rule that the department has set in
a certain area those issues will arise
at some point
but i don't think it's a
i don't i don't think it's something
that can be resolved
today
yeah
i can accept the uh the language as it
is although i i do agree if as you're
going through
the uh actual mechanics of
the next the year or so
the the proposal that uh
that fred had uh outlined makes sense
that you consider
driving
all the initial work into the department
of energy where the staff is and if
there's if there's a conflict then the
puc is the adjudicatory body for
resolution that that makes sense if this
becomes
unworkable okay
um
yeah i i my
instincts are more towards what uh
jackie was saying about the public
utilities commission having the major
role here
because of the fact that this is a
regulatory authority
however i think
because of the way this was restructured
as we know we have people who used to do
one function are now in a department
that really has a different function
and then the question is who takes care
of the regulatory versus planning and
other things
and i think this is going to be a
reoccurring problem
this this is not the only place where
this is going to happen it's going to
happen over and over again because this
is a major overhaul and major shifting
around of people with different
expertise
uh and you you don't you don't want to
lose that expertise but at the same time
now they're under a different authority
so it's really a tricky thing to do and
i think at this point maybe the best
thing would be to leave it as is right
now but to keep a really sharp eye on it
and
as i mentioned a couple times and
requested a couple times
we really need to get a better overview
of this whole reorg from
your department and a lot of the answers
about you know you you provide us with
some comments now that
may be new to us
but not new to you so we need to be up
updated in what's exactly happened where
people are what are what what
authorities got shifted
and i don't think we've gotten that kind
of information as i mentioned the last
time i think we got an update was may of
last year
so that's way too long right thank you
so uh representative mcgee made a
comment at our last meeting
she just wanted to know whether
the structure had been implemented the
way that you were shown and it was
right so
um that
that's the structure that's been
implemented that's where people went in
in terms of
the department or the puc and how the
different divisions are structured
right
um i just just to follow up to i think
peter had an excellent point there this
is not going to be the only issue will
we come in and say
doe
commission both separate one above the
other whatever so rather than try to
come up with a unique solution for each
one i think what i suggest is we just
let you guys know we're going to be
looking at this closely obviously if
there tends to be problems the utilities
and the people that do poll attachments
which are i never there's like a zillion
different companies out there attaching
things to polls these days
they are not shy they will they will let
us know if there's a problem so i think
maybe trying to see what works
rather than try to find a unique
solution to each one maybe the best
approach
i think i think maybe some of the
confusion here is
results from the fact that the
commission
up until hb2 occurred or was passed
the commission was doing a lot of
non-regulatory kinds of things
and what hb2 does is it
gives back to the commission
just those things over which it should
regulate which is mostly rate setting
and it creates the new department of
energy to administer
the rest of
the legislative mandates
uh with regard to energy
so
people have to kind of separate in their
minds
that
the department of energy is
like the department of transportation
can regulate things
relevant to its area of expertise
but the public utilities commission
regulates a very
narrower set of things
than the department of of energy does
and is more adjudicative
in the process because of
the nature of rate setting so i think if
we keep that distinction in our mind
it'll be easier for us to understand why
some of these changes are being
requested
thank you mr chairman um mike i have a
question uh
we've been talking back and forth about
who does what and that we've transferred
resources over that do investigatory
pieces that used to be puc that are now
doe
and
i think
my question is
if the public utilities commission were
the sole responsible party under this
language
they would still have access to those
people for the investigatory piece
of determining any of these issues right
they so they
they become sort of an extended
administrative staff to the puc when
they're doing their work right well
so
let me see if i can come up with an
example as to why it should be both i
mean we have to understand that because
now that
let me see if i can come up with an
example is
why it should be both who have
the the regular retain their authority
over these things okay okay so
if the
issue were to come to the commission
right and the commission wanted the
department's aid
in
understanding the issue yeah right you
the the commission would have to have
authority over something like safety so
that they could make the decision
the department would have to have
authority over safety so that it could
fully go in and investigate
and require answers right
and
require some initial changes right
before maybe before it goes to the
litigation right
so
if you were to just say that the
public utilities commission has control
over it then what would the department
do how would they even help
yeah right so
this is the problem with building the
plane while you're flying it
right is that
i understand there could be endless back
and forth trying to figure out how the
department would work without putting it
in place and then and then tweaking i
understand that there's you know there's
different ways to to approach doing that
and and different values to doing it
each way
but it seems like
the issue still keeps coming back to the
fact that the public utilities
commission no longer has its own
investigatory resources and so it's
going to continue to have this back and
forth with who does what why when who
has authority when where
and that is going to be confusing not
only for the regulatory process but also
for the people who interact with those
two bodies it's not just going to be
internal
um and
i think it's unnecessary i think what
we've done here is an unnecessary
confusion of the two
so let me
see if i can give an example of how it
works right so
um
recently two telephone companies applied
for a boundary exchange
right because we do still regulate some
things having to do with telephone right
so they applied for the boundary
exchange and the commission issued a
procedural order asking the department
to investigate and prepare a
recommendation within a certain amount
of time right now the
red line required the commission to do
that on the record
right so the the companies know
that the department has been requested
to prepare the investigation but
the department has regulatory authority
so they can actually conduct that
investigation
they can they'll file the recommendation
and then the puc will take action
based upon what the utilities have said
and what the
department has recommended
so everything's working
right in terms of where the resources
are and who's doing the work
and everything's on the record so
everybody sees it and that's the
fundamental design i think of house bill
and
it functions
it's working
peter you had a question
thank you
uh yes
i kind of want to respond to what
chairman votes just
mentioned i understand his thinking that
you know we've changed dramatically the
structure of things
and now the department of energy has a
lot more authority and
and authority they didn't have before
um
but this example here with the poll
attachment
is is contradicts that very argument
because then there shouldn't be the puc
in here the theo should be the only one
in here but now you put both together
with
both of them have to agree
and this kind of confusion um is
contradicting maybe the intent of what a
uh
what what should have happened
uh and i don't think that that's going
to get resolved easily uh
just because of the just this one item
here so in the context of this statute
both do not have to agree
poll attachment issues do not go to the
puc at all
unless the
the poll owner and the person who wishes
to attach
can't come to an agreement
right if they can't come to an agreement
as to the terms and conditions and
pricing of the poll attachment statute
that all goes to the puc for litigation
right so
that's all that's going there now there
might be a safety issue involved you
know where
um an attacher wants to attach in the
electric space right and the commission
is going to say absolutely not you can't
do that right just as the department
would say absolutely not you can't do
that
but but the sentence says
like
michael was just saying before
retain their authority so on the one
hand you say this is a puc issue
uh
they're the people of having the
authority to do this
but then
it talks about the department of energy
retaining some authority over it well
they didn't have authority before right
so this is something new
but i think you're you're looking at it
in terms of when the statute is enacted
as opposed to where this falls in the
process
right so this is where it falls in the
process excuse me though i would just
because i was wrong on that the hb2
presently gives the authority to the
department of energy so they are
retaining it so that it is the correct
term i i just i just read it wrong
already
and they retained that so this
i suggest expanding that but beyond
beyond that
i don't that this really has to do
with where the paragraph falls in the
process of attachments not where it
falls in the process of
adopting statutes
not it's so it's not on that small slice
of that process exactly right so all
this is saying
is that in the process
of
entering into a poll attachment
agreement
the utility
and the attacher cannot
bargain away the state's authority to
regulate
right so when you're in that process
regardless of who has that authority
that's correct okay yeah
so yeah this doesn't deal with who has
the authority or what authorities they
hold it's just whatever we hold
you can't bargain it away
whatever you agree to
doesn't matter we're going to come in
we're going to regulate safety
right okay we're going to have to move
on because we can battle this thing uh
for forever so going down the rest of
the page it looks to me
under section 23 that these are just uh
changes which i think were in the
original from commission to department
of energy
there's a number of those i i'd like to
look at number four on line 15.
um
what page you want we're on i'm on eight
before we're
glossing by the rest of what's on that
page um under open access to
transmission and distribution facilities
we're leaving the first sentence and i
would like to ask whether we could leave
the last sentence as well
which i think has relevance in the
statute
and was there for a reason
the commission in the department should
monitor companies providing transmission
of distribution services and take
necessary measures to ensure that no
supplier has an unfair advantage in
offering and pricing such services
i think that
language was there specifically
to make sure that that is taken into
consideration under
uh open access to transmission and
distribution facilities
and it was part of the original
restructuring policy principles so
um i
think that that language should be
retained
i think that's up to you you folks and
we'll do that work if you ask us to i
know so the sentence says the the
sentence that representative mcgee
referred to says the commission and the
department was that changed in hb2 was
that language changed in hb2
what department is
the sentence referring to
yeah it would be doe because in the in
hb2 it said that those would be the
references right department would be
doing so that's where it came from i'm
sure
i think it's a valid request i don't see
why we wouldn't want to leave it in
unless someone sees something i'm
missing
so i think representative mcgee is right
on the money you want to put that one
back in then
so that's on line 20 of page four thank
you page eight i'm sorry
okay
okay so
section 23
is one that we've talked about a couple
of times
this is a rate payer protection
provision
and
has to do with
providing notice of when you're
going to use a variable rate
and the appropriate party to report that
to would be the department because we're
the people who listed on the website yes
yes
so section 24 at the bottom of the page
has to do with the so-called
sbc report
that is provided to the legislature
every year
and
house bill 2 had the commission and the
department submitting that report but
the commission really doesn't have
anything
to
of its own to say about that
so our recommendation was that you just
have the department prepare and submit
that report
section 25 on page nine
this is another one of those sections
sort of similar to the one we were
discussing before in that you're going
to have two
the two groups of department and the
commission having to really work
together here i mean for example i know
one of the commissioners was just down
at the nay roof meeting in washington
where they passed a resolution between
ferc and nehru to work on
some transmission siting rules
and obviously
when we get back to new hampshire the
the part of this our state that's going
to be working on the transmission issues
dealing with knee pool and iso new
england is going to be the department of
energy and not the puc so
the sentence you added in here employees
of the commission and department are not
otherwise prohibited from participating
etc it was definitely needed but again
just a heads up on this one this is an
area where we could have potential
conflict and we're going to have to make
sure that the two groups work together
seamlessly because these things aren't
that clear especially once you start
going into regional issues
um
section 26 beginning on line 22. uh this
was in the original
uh
house bill 1258 has introduced
so no changes there
excuse me could you say that again
please how it was where
um
so beginning on page line 22 on page
nine
section 26
we did not make any changes to that that
this is how it appeared in
house bill 1258 as introduced
so this is all language you've seen
before
oh okay yeah so did this uh result from
last year's senate bill 91
as i recall yes yes okay thank you
so section 27 was also when uh the bill
is introduced it's just a
reference change in the budget
from
adjudicative commissioners back to
public utilities commission
i think because adjudicative
commissioners is difficult to say
then um
section 28
that took out the repeal of the
um
rsa 374 f34
that's on page eight now
and um
so the open access transmission
provision
in house bill 1258 that was completely
repealed
right so you'll no no longer see that in
the
in the repeal section
on section 28 then these are repealed
this was in
hb2 or 1258 as originally submitted or
okay so um
rsa 12 p12
was a mistake in house bill 2 because
that provision actually appears in the
pucs
own statutes
so that's just a housekeeping measure
okay
two three and four the 371 sites those
are changes to the crossing statute
these are the exemptions that are being
removed so that everybody comes in
to get a license right
and then
rsa 374 f35b
we
that that repeal was in 1258 as
introduced and that's because that
provision has been superseded
by time right thank you
so
go ahead there was one mistake that i
made
find it here in the uh
provisions i think it was section eight
we're losing your volume david if you
could just get a little closer please
what section did that end up in
okay no mistakes made
if we're through i'd like to summarize
how
what what changes we still need to make
so we get a another
amendment it's complete
and the ones that i remember is putting
back in the five-year you have five
years to
change rules yeah but actually i think
that was intended to go
in section six
where we're getting the exemption from
541a172 which page you want that would
be page two line 16. i think that's
where you had actually talked about the
five-year
okay as long as we get it in there then
okay so page 2916.
just so you note down to provide
language
second was uh the uh
the mcgee uh
uh
the uh amendment with respect to uh the
uh database
which should be incorporated in here
okay
that we haven't addressed it let's just
give a can we go over what we've done
so far today and then we'll get to that
afterwards so go ahead freddie
well just i'm just summarizing what i
thought what changes
third that i remember is adding back a
sentence
that was deleted
on page eight lines uh
16 to 22 the last sentence starting the
commissioner of the department should be
added back in
okay
those are the changes i remember that's
that's the ones i had written down as
well so if anyone has anything else okay
okay
then uh in addition to that i said that
i would be sending around some
additional changes to rsa 125.0
just in terms of changing department to
commission or
some some very simple changes to that
we have the
so-called mcgee amendment uh so where is
and
okay it's i'm sorry what
for the dyslexic
and
i mean this is only this is just this
build is a lot more yeah
the language in 1285 which i didn't
bring my full book with me so i don't
have it michael can you help out here
um i think you already did send that
along to ols though right the bill
well
matthew young who was the ols attorney
informed me that mr shulock had
addressed this in his document but i
didn't see anything in the document we
supplied to os ols that addressed this
change house bill 1285
yeah the statewide energy data platform
with the security and privacy language
we had just agreed that we can itl that
bill if we can include that language
here and updating
the language around doe okay
so in the last
change okay so in the language that i
send you you want me to include the
language from 1285. that'd be helpful
yes
that way we can be assured it gets in
mr young apparently got confused when i
asked him to put it in because he didn't
know where it came from i guess
you should start attending our meetings
just a question is hb 1285 has not been
amended it's it's hb 25 1285 he can get
as introduced and incorporate it thank
you
okay so we've got uh three changes
um when do you think as far as time wise
goes and i'll defer to the chairman on
this when do we need this buy let me put
it that way
we're executing this bill on tuesday
march 1st
which is a week from today
so we would need the completed amendment
by
friday of this week
so it'll have to go
your document mr sherlock will have to
go to representative harrington he'll
have to contact ols to get the amendment
drafted because i'm going out of town
okay so so is is wednesday okay yeah the
only drawback i say
michael said friday but we're talking
about a snowstorm friday so maybe als
ols isn't here i'll do my best to give
it to you tomorrow yeah or even even
what's today tuesday late wednesday you
know
whatever time or early thursday so i
could get it to them uh
just in case there was a storm and
things get closed and i'm hoping then
based on that we can take the amendment
as is to the executive committee uh or
to execute on
what is it monday we have that tuesday
march 1st tuesday march 1st okay
so i'll make sure when i get the thing
from uh when i get it back i'll
distribute it to the entire committee i
guess i'll be the best okay so does
anything have anything else on here
i just want to thank everybody for
showing up uh spent a lot of time on
this i wanted to thank the people from
the department of energy you've been
more than helpful you've uh we couldn't
have done it without you and hopefully
we're making your life a little easier
and uh we look forward to realizing you
probably be back with some additional
changes as you work out a few more kinks
in this but we'll take it one step at a
time and hopefully make the process
better so with that i'll adjourn the
subcommittee hearing
you